I had to see the film watched it was
horrified it stuck in my mind have no
interest in revisiting it and it left
quite an impression
can you name a movie that is absolutely
incredible not Star Wars that you've
seen over a dozen times
well let's
let's um
a movie that I've seen over a dozen
times that is
a movie that also I come back to
to kind of renew my faith in movies is
Blade Runner I think by Ridley Scott The
World building in Blade Runner the
sci-fi film noir
um
you know Harrison Ford's performance
very unlike
how we knew Harrison Ford when he played
Han Solo
and I think that that film has been
incredibly influential not just with
other movies other dystopian films
because dystopian films of that era
didn't necessarily take themselves too
seriously you know they were
um borderline like sci-fi Adventure
comedies but um
you know Blade Runner is a classic
and it it has you know it's it's
influential till today not just in
movies but also in video games and in
design and it's funny you know
it's it's really funny looking at how
Forward Thinking Blade Runner is in the
sense that okay we don't have flying
cars
but we we do have many of the things
that are in Blade Runner La has become
very Multicultural much more than uh the
time in which it was made
so that's a movie I can just put on
anytime
and watch
yeah and I think Philip K dick talked
about
um that he envisioned a world where the
higher Social strata would live up top
and and as people's income and sort of
like place in society yeah they would be
more toward the bottom I mean Blade
Runner in a way kind of predicted the uh
economic divide that we're currently
experiencing
with more and more people being pushed
from the middle class
to lower middle class or worse and a
huge divide between the elites and
everybody else
and it's unfortunate but that that movie
that's that's an element of Blade Runner
can you tell us about the movies that we
want to watch over and over again versus
the movies we just want to see one time
maybe they were satisfying enough but
we're good one and done
I think that the movies that we watch
over and over again uh were seeking one
comfort food it's a film I'm familiar
with
2001 A Space Odyssey is a movie that
I'll watch several times a year and if
it's at a retrospective screening I'll
be sitting in a perfect spot in the
theater for that movie but I think we're
seeking some kind of meaning and I will
say with the films that I do repeatedly
view they're ones that I saw probably an
impressionable age
but also I'm looking at it differently
so it's interesting to see a film I saw
when I was say 11 years old like Logan's
Run
okay and then I see it differently now
as an adult
uh and and so that's what's that's why
what I find fascinating about films that
we watch on repeat or will have repeated
viewings at different phases of life
because it's in some way kind of a
reflection of us
and and so those films for me are you
know movies like a Logan's Run or a 2001
A Space Odyssey or Tron and and it's
funny that those movies perhaps with the
exception of Logan's Runner still
remembered
um I think Logan's Run is more revered
for the performances of Michael York and
Jenny agatar than than the actual
special effects
your mileage may vary on the special
effects for that film but 2001
holds up to today and I don't think that
we would have had a Star Wars or George
Lucas if Stanley Kubrick had not made
2001 because 2001 A Space Odyssey the
special effects from that film actually
directly influenced George Lucas he
thought well now I can make a science
fiction film with spaceships and laser
guns but I want it to be taken seriously
I don't want it to be a joke but those
those films we we revisit we're trying
to revisit I think I think it's a
reflection of us now and that's also
revisiting perhaps who you were when
that movie made an impression
so I think of myself as a kid being
dropped off at the movie theater in
Michigan by my mom to go see Logan's Run
which was PG and probably shouldn't been
there's an ample amount of nudity and
and deeper themes in that film
um but but that that is a film that
resonates for me today that you could
hardly convince anyone now to watch it
because it definitely feels the special
effects are dated for sure but I don't
know that you'll find a better romance
in a in a science fiction film than
Logan's Run
so I kind of
I kind of revisit that film it was you
know
um seeing that you know by myself seeing
it in a theater a couple times after
that
um when it came to the dollar theater
and then also kind of was my first
interest in in you know I I was a young
boy I liked girls and so that movie was
a romance and uh
so yeah it reminds me of just being a
kid and that was sort of my first
interest in girls was was seeing Logan's
Run oddly
what's interesting when you when we
re-watch a movie let's say like Kramer
versus Kramer which I probably saw way
too young but I thought it was so funny
but now as an adult you watch it and
it's it's very sad it's it's yeah Kramer
versus Kramer is heartbreaking it's not
um I mean there are a lot of uh you know
moments of levity for sure right a lot
but but there are there's so much more
going on I do think that that era in the
70s and even like partially into the 80s
was such a great
era of American filmmaking you know I I
I tell people revisit those films that
was when there was less far less Studio
influence
studios in fact didn't really know what
to do you know the marketing in
particular uh wasn't as sophisticated as
it is now or as controlled and I mean
that in a good way
I go back and watch the original
trailers for any movie from the 70s they
didn't know how to make a movie trailer
back then or at least they didn't have
the sort of very traditional kind of
trailery things that we see the the
voice over the certain certain types of
musical notes and themes that are
overused quite a bit and you know
um you you could look up videos on this
there are so many so many ways that they
test these trailers because they're
tracking emotion there's certain
emotions and beats that they want to hit
in addition to basically ruining most of
the movie up until potentially the third
act and if you're familiar with the
genre you can probably figure out what's
going to happen it's rare I see a
trailer these days for a studio movie
that doesn't completely ruin the entire
film
is that theater still there in Michigan
I don't believe it is unfortunately it
was uh the Berkeley Theater was turned
into a drugstore
the Berkeley Theater was walking
distance or at least bicycle distance
from my house and I would go see movies
every week at that theater it was
because it was only a dollar and there
was a drugstore directly next door where
I bought comic books
can you name a movie that was absolutely
incredible to watch but you've only seen
it one time
uh yes
and I'm sad to tell you it was the human
centipede
uh there there was if you know anything
about the story of The Human Centipede
it's absolutely horrific and I'm not
going to describe it for you
um do your research at your peril but
that's a film I saw once because I had
to see it
um and I I did review it for a a job at
the time I was doing movie reviews on on
G4 TV
and I had to see the film watched it was
horrified it stuck in my mind have no
interest in revisiting it and it left
quite an impression
but normally movies I only see once I
only see them once for a reason and
that's because they're not very good
and I don't wish to revisit them
um Human Centipede I thought just the
concept of it it's it's horrifying and I
guess what what did stand out to me is
that it's not as as graphic from a
horror standpoint as you might think
it's it's much more psychological that's
the type of horror film that I prefer is
a psychological horror film because I
feel like
you know that is a movie that will stay
with you
that is a movie that when you
turn off the lights at night
to to go to sleep is going to still be
in your head
and maybe you want to turn the light
back on and read a book
to kind of change the change the sort of
hamster wheel uh spinning around in your
head about about a move and that's where
I knew a movie is is really good is when
I can't stop thinking about it
most unfortunately a lot of films that I
see I'll see one time and and they're
fairly forgettable you know they're
they're sort of that middle ground it's
the ones that are really bad or really
exceptional are the ones that stand out
in my memory there's another class of
movies I I think that like almost
require a second viewing in order to
fully experience them
I'll give you a couple of examples the
movie memento
Christopher Nolan's second feature film
starring Guy Pierce is a movie that upon
second viewing
you'll you'll notice all the details
that you missed
and and so that one really really left
an impression on me another film I would
say Darren Aronofsky is the fountain
it's not one that's brought up too often
um
but that film really really left an
impression upon me I think Darren
Aronofsky is a brilliant filmmaker and
the fountain is another one that I
believe you can appreciate more upon
second viewing because you have things
happening in different time periods kind
of that that are
reflecting or echoing each other so to
speak so I do think that in addition to
movies you may only see once I think
that movies that that require a second
viewing to to gain more from it I think
are are really important to explore